en contra en allí bukele y sus políticas
miles de salvadoreños volvieron a
marchar en las calles contra el
mandatario de su país el autoritarismo
mostrado por el político su defensa de
la adopción del bitcoin como moneda
oficial o la falta de transparencia
gubernamental son algunas de las muchas
causas por las que la oposición decidió
salir
[Música]
bukele está muy desaparecido de la vida
pública y apenas comparece en ruedas de
prensa y ofrece entrevistas de hecho de
forma habitual utiliza la red social
'twitter' para dar sus anuncios de
gobierno un lugar donde se define como
emperador de el salvador precisamente
desde twitter ha cargado contra los
manifestantes e incluso se ha mofado por
lo que considera una asistencia baja en
las protestas acarreando ancianos que no
saben ni el propósito de la marcha en
plena pandemia porque odian tanto a
nuestro pueblo qué bueno que fracasó su
marcha tal vez cambian y dejan de tratar
así a nuestra gente más humildes
bukele terminó con el sistema
tradicional de partidos del salvador con
su victoria en 2019 y a pesar de su
controvertida figura sigue gozando de
niveles muy altos de popularidad entre
la población le otorga impunidad